hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to inside now I think
if I had to guess about inside and what
inside means we're inside the machine
we're inside the sewers which is very
apt description of where we are and
we're inside the realm where markimoo is
not smart enough to keep this guy away
from death hello hi sir are you friendly
I guarantee not I'm going to find a way
to push you oh don't mind me
don't buy me what dad Uncle Ben Uncle OH
why whoa it's crazies what kind of
society is is where they just run up and
kill the first child they see my
goodness this is no good like unless I
have some sort of distinguishing remarks
on me or marks on me why is their first
instinct it's a kid kill him kill him
dead Meryem choke him up against the
railing for some [ __ ] reason who
knows I don't know
does anybody know I don't know okay
bye-bye I'm gonna steal your submarine
I'm gonna steal it cuz I'm a rebel and
I'm awesome so goodbye my now [ __ ] oh
free ride somehow as a child I know how
to pilot this but frankly I'm not
surprised can I go farther down no I'm
gonna oh I love this
oh it's so cool I love the diversity
like the diversity in this game is
phenomenal like the different
environments is one thing traveling
through the world that's that's one
thing entirely but this is like it's a
shift it's like the same concept but in
a different light like making a vehicle
a part of it it's just it's pretty cool
I don't know why I thought it was gonna
pass through the floor
I'm really drying here it's not working
though that's not working though okay so
that's a blank wall over there that's
just nothing over there so like
something awesome oh it's terrifying
down here oh I don't like this at all
oh god I do not like this what is this
where is this city built that there
underneath what is that oh that's crack
in the wall but there's a giant chain
over there is that a chain I can't tell
what that is but there's something
gigantic in the background there it's
huge I know I need to crack that but man
what is this place where are they
there's so many unanswered questions and
I love it I love like a story that
doesn't tell itself completely right off
the bat it's it's told there's a certain
word for it but it's a game that story
is told in the environment and that's
what I could really appreciate let you
glean like this whole universe exists
and the thing about game it's a visual
medium so of course you can like execute
these ideas through just telling about
the environment and then you can infer
your own interpretation about it boo-ki
I gotta charge up better for those man I
hope I get to do that a million times
over because that is the coolest power
I've ever had and thankfully nothing can
harm me out here I'm totally safe that
weird red ominous glow in the distance
is nothing bad for me and I'm going to
be a-ok even though I'm going farther
and farther down which doesn't bode
I loved his his Riggin whiplash this kid
gets oh that's so cool he animations
inside of the thing it's so cool there
we go do I get a boost through that I'll
do it I probably don't dad don't
ooh what is that why is that a projector
screen that's weird why is that in there
this used to be a classroom or something
Oh God oh it's building inside to me oh
oh oh it's reinforced I'm gonna do it
again
Oh God Oh No Oh save yourself
boring hello oh it's so cool I'm gonna
get it yeah yeah yeah man one more one
more one more
did that do it did I just give myself a
concussion here is that just not gonna
work because it's reinforced concrete
probably we've breached ok so there's
something over here maybe I can launch
myself out of the water that'd be
totally awesome and I'd love that but at
the same time I bet that's not the case
but maybe it is the case ok I'm gonna do
that oh I see what it's doing oh it's a
crack leading upwards so I did need to
keep what I was doing more MORE ok
there's more to this it's cracked
forming whoops oh I meant to go more
horizontal than that this poor kid he's
getting the [ __ ] beat up this is
probably definitely not what this thing
was built for but just continually gets
abused like this by this small child oh
I didn't know about that
oh I didn't know I could hop out of the
thing Oh
so I opened up probably a hole big
enough for me to get through don't drown
don't drown hang on don't drown come on
so if I can't get through there then I
must be able to yeah I just swim through
well who defunct it would have been that
easy not me not me I tells you so does
that mean that I can open it up for
ophélie my ship to come bursting through
nope we got to do this the old-fashioned
way without a fun ship that saves us
from death but I don't know if it would
have been in the universe to have a
giant monster come attack me but that
would have been cool and all I just for
some reason didn't even think of the
possibility to let him go the one cool
thing that I had in this world not
saying this world is cool I'm saying
this poor kid only had one thing to his
name and it was that ship and it was so
cool all right so what are we doing here
so this seems to be an old decrepit
school which would explain the projector
that we had in the other room over there
but it would not explain why this world
is so [ __ ] well I mean it kana would
explain why this world is so [ __ ] up
because there's just a lot of [ __ ]
that's going on this is gonna kill me
out Kabul's
I stopped for some reason because I
thought I could open the hatch and that
would have been a stupid Avenue and I
don't know I even tried there's a lot of
my life I don't even know why I try okay
what about that so that was good that
was nice
oh good I got a tube to keep floating
and what good does that do me except
nothing okay so I can go back and I can
go through the door without the risk of
dying a horrible death by rattie's I
scared you once why'd you come back
I'll maybe come back again see best
never return to this place ever ever
again you
dooty rats carrying on so they've got to
be something every why does that look
like the projector screen in the other
room over there like why is that there
who knows why is any of this here why is
this a school here it reminds me of like
Midgar from Final Fantasy 7 a city built
on top of a city is that a land mine
something tells me that might be an
exploding device whoo what do you do
what I do what I do oh that that is not
what I expected to happen
I expected that to blast me into the
next universe blast me up a bit which is
awfully nice of it okay thank you you're
a delightful device I don't know what
your purpose is but you're really cool
okay so what do we got over you know
it's interesting that the developers ran
with the same fundamental concept of a
game considering the glass game was a
child wandering through an unknown
universe full of perils and this is a
universe full of perils both like
technically speaking similar ideas if
not like identical ideas on paper but
like the execution is still
fascinatingly interesting because I mean
like it's one of those things where it's
it's not really something that that can
only be done once you know there's if if
like McDonald's Wendy's Burger King can
all sell oh boy
bubble buddy's back if like they can all
sell the same burger in this region
quite a bit for my my idea here but if
they can all sell the same burger I
don't understand why the same
fundamental concept can be redone the
only reason that I'm mentioning this is
that it's fascinating that the
developers did it the the exact same
theme again which I what the [ __ ] was
that I'll stop talking about the game as
if I know anything because I do not all
right now I go hippity hop over
boy I do not pretend like I know what
I'm doing wolf some bad is down here I
thought they weren't gonna have anything
for me oh you think that's going to stop
me that's what I thought all right you
sign the [ __ ] down here what are you
doing this is gonna open for me oh it
does but is there something down here
hang on
peekaboo for just a second oh man I'm
just tempted to explore all the
environments but I don't know ah look at
you
I found something okay all right be
using my big brain what do we got over
here
what do we got this is where the
monsters lurk so deep down in the
darkness probably me me okay so what is
this where is this Oh fascinating
I don't know if I can reach that Hey
bail bail bail bail ah damn it okay so I
can't reach that yet though can i huh I
can't right
no yeah you can't oh there's a ladder
over there okay that's what I was
looking for okay I wouldn't have thought
they would have put something very
secret like that was a secret that
probably wasn't gonna be evil to easily
found
but I found it nonetheless John van you
do the thing
oops sorry yeah almost had it come on
Kenny can you stop goofing around I know
this is the first little bit of freedom
that you've had as a horrible
zombie-like person but tell me
okay so there's got to be a way to do
this that I can get him in there so if
he's if he's on top of it no no okay
so if he's on top of it and then I get
in it and then he gets boost up into
that thing then he should just yeah yeah
you're gonna be fine
don't worry about it husky yeah yeah man
yeah Mon okay so we get out of there I'm
gonna leave that there just in case I
need him to go over there but I do not
think I do so if he's over there that
means we got control of the second do
daddy
we should be good walking Ewok hippity
hop over the cam shop boink boink boink
okay
oh that guy died oh no this is gonna be
hanging there for all eternity well
that's mean so what did that do oh is
this not actually a secret and is this
actually something that I needed to find
is that what this was
ah come on okay so that probably
unpowered something that's gonna be in
the other area and then that's where we
needed to go and then everything's gonna
be fine and I'm not that smart I'm just
a little ahead of the curve but oh
hit Bluth alright so if that was that
that means that this would unlock
something over yeah wait where's that
wire going I see the cable I see the
cable where does that go what kind of
ended where to go where'd you go where'd
you go you cable bastard something over
here maybe what is that I don't think
it's actually anything yeah I don't
think that was actually to anything I
mean it couldn't have been to nothing
that that's the number one thing to
understand from this thing it could it
literally couldn't have been to nothing
maybe it was something over there and I
just didn't get to it yet oh wait
there's more hang on what's up here no
all right I guess that's not it ah I
feel like maybe maybe you guys are very
angry at me because I found a secret and
then immediately walked away from a
secret which would be a really shitty
thing for me to do but then again maybe
this wasn't powered and maybe it was
totally fine I don't know all right I'm
gonna hop out of here I'm gonna try to
get to that but 10 it's pretty far down
but I think it should be okay he'd be
yeah okey-dokey then
alrighty get some air don't drown number
one priority here
it's not a pile of you somewhere you're
not gonna get stuck okay that's not very
deep but did that help us damnit I don't
see what that huh I don't see what the
deactivation signal did didn't actually
do anything
can I launch around here somewhere
I could get out and get through here
maybe yeah I can get out and get through
here but is there some reason for me to
be over here yet I don't know I don't
even know if there are secrets in this
game I just realize how vulnerable I am
I saw that monster thing and now I'm in
that area that that it is oh [ __ ] I
should have gotten more air oh I should
have gotten more air up now I'm dead
well that went well for me but I mean if
the water level is up then I can get
over it why did I lower the water level
I didn't actually need to do that I'm
very confused I don't think I needed to
do that it was just a shiny red button
right in front of my face how could I
ignore it so if the water level is
higher than I can actually launch myself
or I can just swim over the obstacle
yeah this isn't a problem at all but the
thing isn't open so I got to swim back
oh it all makes sense now okay so I just
had to do that first and then push the
button by myself far away from my device
that protects me from the denizens of
the deep so that's good well it's not
good because I'm gonna be all alone and
terrified but it's good in that it's
gonna help me progress
right here buhdeuce already uh don't
drown come on don't drown and stop
coughing underwater
you've been holding your breath for like
ten seconds you'd think that you could
do a little more than that alright but
it's fine I'm not complaining about the
survival skills if it's likely like 12
year old kid alright let us away I
thought that was something there's just
a reflection of the water that's the
stuff now we're on track okay so fur on
track here we can boost through there
are you what are you what are you what
are you hey hey hey
why can you breathe underwater and why
is your hair so gosh-darn long I won't
get you I'm gonna get you I'm asking
whoa you're a fast one husky I'm gonna
name you Sally or Emma I'm gonna name
you every single random name that pops
into my head as we're going through this
story Oh Samantha how you doin Samantha
throw away who did I named Samantha I
can't remember
how'd you Oh God oh god I am dead well
that's not good maybe I need to shake
her off once that happens okay probably
hey hey hey
nope that ain't it well huh yeah I don't
know how she's able to do that I don't
think I want to see what's going on in
there
probably horrible maybe I just got to
keep a light on her that must be it yeah
it's like peekaboo hey hey hey yeah you
better back off you better back off
hey hey I'm getting angry
I'm asking so she's over peekaboo
yeah that's what I thought Samantha Roy
sorry
well should I shine it on why the [ __ ]
did not shine on oh that's stupid I
shined it right on it just I hit the
ground and I got stunned that's what it
was it was my own damn fault didn't mean
to do that I got you in my sights I got
your number now not that I wanted to in
the first place Samantha hey how about
you don't huh
how about you just don't shoot Dee
II
yeah okay so we're making progress we're
doing good wet wet wet there we go good
thing in Auto tracks because that that's
definitely beneficial so where I know
where I need to go wait wait no I see it
no oh I know what I need to do I need to
know god damn it not then that's not
what I wanted to do I wanted to go down
an auto track do it yeah I was pushing
straight down it does that thing where
it guides you along where it wants you
to go I need to get her on one side and
then close the door on her and that's
what I need to do okay
I got no okay so I just need to keep it
right there
and then slam this shut on her right
there I am she done okay God that is
peasy lemon squeeze me okay
so now that that's taken care of I can
figure out the [ __ ] Ram or the [ __ ]
oh I know what I need to do what would
happen if I would just bash through this
while she was here I thought about dupes
oh because you need multiple batches and
it breaks your light I see okie dokie
that's why it was that makes more sense
so how many more of those things are
they and why is that thing even a thing
that exists well I think I'm done
am I done with this we're good I think I
might be done with this okay
so hop out and we are on the beach so
anyway that is all for this episode here
we're getting into some really
interesting stuff here
like this game already I like it a lot
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video oh [ __ ]